diesen schneeball diesen unfassbar
glänzenden schneeball ich werfe den
hierhin und ihr seht der schneeball
kreiert ein komplettes dorf der
generiert ein komplettes tor verdammte
scheiße gemacht ein ganzes dorf erst
perfekte chance so ist man in zweifel
games unter wasser immer safe richtig
nervig du sagst etwas und wiederholt es
einfach 2000 mal 2000 mal 2000 mal 2000
mal 2000 mal 2002 wusste jeder außer du
und der andere sparten namens kock ecke
komme und vor allem war das gar keinen
euro mehr hätte ich ein keks würde ich
ihm geben und damit herzlich willkommen
meine lieben freunde hier zu einer neuen
folge minecraft facts am samstag ja ich
hab eigentlich gesagt dass die man am
dienstag und am freitag kommen aber ich
hab's gestern total nicht mehr geschafft
weil ich in hamburg war und alle die mir
jetzt integration minecraft musiker
nicht habe ich kann naja jedenfalls alle
die mir auf twitter folgen haben gewusst
warum nichts kam weil ich meiner wohnung
in hamburg und habe ich fotos gepostet
und wie ich das umgeräumt habe und ich
bin ja jetzt schon so halb umgezogen
schon die ganze zeit ist doch relativ
egal ist doch gar nicht ich würde
einfach sagen dass wir anfangen mit dem
effekt ich hab gedacht ich will das
jetzt heute am samstag nach bevor ich
die gar nicht mache das zweite mal in
dieser woche heute kommt er keinesfalls
geräusch und ich würde sagen gefangen
mit dem ersten tag der mir zu gesendet
wurde von allen also an
denn heißt er oder sie ich weiß nicht ob
sein er oder sie ist weil er oder sie
mit herzchen geschrieben hat deswegen
hat er eine sie aber ist relativ egal
jedenfalls schon sehr oft zugesendet ich
habe jetzt gedacht nur da ist mir so auf
zugesendet wird nehme ich ihn doch
einfach mal dran und zwar seht ihr hier
schon da als lava die fließt ganz
einfach runter und die hinter ist ein
spalt können jetzt einfach mit den
kirchen reinpacken ich pack das
beispielsweise mal einen scharf packe
ich da mal rein und schwein weil man das
daran relativ gut sehen kann und zwar
nehme ich jetzt einfach schon die
ausgeklügelte minecraft spieler kennt
natürlich schon da könnte ich auch
direkt wieder sein kommentar formen und
nach dem intro anwenden
jedenfalls die schiesser ein pfeil durch
die aber durch das hat nicht geklappt
ein fall durch die läufer durch und wir
sehen dieser fall hat angefangen zu
brennen ich zeige es euch mal hier
beispielsweise hat man das ganz kurz
gesehen so da der pfeil brennt wenn
jetzt beispielsweise mal auf das
schweigen schießen moment hier so
zachmann ich treffe hier auch nicht
ehrlich vollidiot ich schieb mal von
hier ich glaube der mitte treffen sollte
um das hübsche mädels das ganze
angefangen zu brennen und manchmal hat
man auch die chance das tier dann
beispielsweise irgendwie sonnen
gebratene ist da draußen gebratenes
stück fleisch herauskommt dass ich mache
jetzt hier noch mal so da hat das
schwein ist beispielsweise gebraten und
jetzt habt ihr hier seht ihr hier da
kommt ein guckt matten raus das ist ja
dieses fleisch dieses lammfleisch ist
man das nicht auf einen döner ich will
mir gar nicht so sicher
dahinter ist auch noch ein schaf haben
wir da auch ja jetzt haben wir auch die
disco platten also wenn ihr quasi eine
tierfarm habt irgendwie und sehr sehr
viele weise nicht kühl haben kühe jetzt
auch vielleicht ich weiß es nicht
jedenfalls ganz viele schweine oder so
dann machte einfach so eine wand vor und
schießt die dann alle ab oder brennt sie
gleich alle an
wenn dann habt ihr halt immer so die
sicherheit dass das ganze direkt schon
apparate sind die keine kohle mehr
verschwenden müsst also danke an dich
eltern oder allein für diesen coolen
verkommen wird zum zweiten fake der mir
zu gesendet wurde von michael und zwar
meint michael wir können doch einfach
mal in den game mode 3 gegen den kennen
wir ja schon bereits dann wird ihr alles
irgendwie abgedunkelt weil ich
wahrscheinlich gerade eine blockt und
bin ja genau ich kann hier durch die
welt durch fliegen kann ja alles mir mal
so ein bisschen begutachten anschauen et
cetera
allerdings meint er wenn jetzt eine
beliebige taste drücken also ihnen eine
taste von 1 bis 9 drücke ich mal einfach
seht ihr unten ist die taskleiste
diese inventar leiste und die
verschwindet jetzt direkt wieder weil
wir keine tasse gelebt haben jedenfalls
kann die 1 drücken dann sehen wir einst
teleport to play arbeiter 27 wir
teleport team member das ist ganz gut
für server also wenn ihr irgendwie auf
dem server seid könnt ihr euch da mal zu
eurem teamspielern teleportieren ich
hab's noch nie ausprobiert aber ich
denke dafür wird es da sein mit wenn wir
irgend jetzt eine andere taste drücken
oder irgendwie sowas also wir können es
erstmal das menü kurz wieder
verschwinden lassen so wenn wir
beispielsweise die fünf drücken damit
das ganze aufgerufen wird mit ring
jetzigen die zahl von 3 bis 7 dann
passiert gar nichts ich drücke die ganze
drei vier fünf sechs sieben passiert gar
nichts so jedenfalls die abdrücken
können wir auf die nächste seite gehen
die gibt es allerdings noch nicht also
da ist noch nichts vorhanden nehmen
nächste seite von diesem commands und
wenn wir auf die neuen brücken stießen
wir das ganze wieder das also wir müssen
dann kann sie die neuen drücken wenn
dann wieder die neuen actros menge unter
9 um das ganze zu schließen genauso wie
eine taste drücken das ganze aufzurufen
dann drücken wir die einzelnen porto
player und dann können die eindrücke zu
einem spieler teleportieren und dann
funktioniert also 112 funktioniert offen
server an diesen ex page gibt es
monatlich keine ahnung was das bedeutet
wenn jetzt ist schreibt kommentare und
neun schließen das ganze wieder ist
relativ cool ich wusste nicht dass es so
was im game 3 gibt und dann würde ich
sagen dann kann infekten jetzt kommt zum
dritten
der dritte weg wurde mir zugesendet von
schiers lp und zwar am main 14 p es gibt
ja dieses neue amors denn wo man seine
rüstung irgendwie dran packen kann und
blabla etc jedenfalls kann man wenn man
einen bogen hat kann man dieses arm aus
stellen kaputt schießen normalerweise
kann man mit dem bogen nahezu nichts
kaputt schießen also keine blöcke oder
erst recht nicht in sonst stabilen arm
ostend man kann mit den bürgern in die
so was ich glaube man kann bilder
abschießen man kann bilderrahmen hat
schießen allerdings kann man auch einen
kompletten arm aus und damit kaputt
schießen man schießt da nämlich einfach
gegen ist diese arm aus den weg
eigentlich fallen die sachen runter also
dass es im game modi 0 der fall wenn man
im zweifel ist weil die sachen auch
runter oder warte war das jetzt einfach
nur ein komischer fehler wie texten ist
natürlich man direkt aus ich nehme was
er denn da war glaube ich irgendwo in
dem einfach mal den arm osten und packen
als mal eine display dran so dann gehen
wir mal den game zu null so jetzt hab
ich gar kein freilich so dass der arm
aus und ich bin gern schießen ab und da
seht ihr schon damit
im ostend gedroppt und die display also
das ist wohl nur ein game hat ein so
dass dann komplett kaputt geht aber man
kann auf jeden fall mit einem fall den
arm aus den cappuccinos wenn ihn
gekriegt habe schießt aber den abstand
kaputt
dies bot die rüstung oder wenn ihr seht
ich bin schon im krieg schnell kaputt
schießen und dann habt ihr in eure
richtung der vierte wurde mir nicht
wirklich zugesendet er wurde mir
zugesperrt immens viele leute haben mir
als ich sagte ab schickt mir facts die
eventuell mit der einzige preis zu tun
haben die mir das sie geschrieben mann
kam mit doppel wie vorher oder steuerung
beim fliegen schneller fliegen das
andere finger nicht mehr auf das schild
aufgepasst in der grob fassung also wir
können ja ganz normal sprint mit doppelt
weh das kennt ihr wenn ich jetzt in
games bin und fliege dann fliege ich
viel schneller
normalerweise fliege ich so schnell wenn
ich also ganz normal wege rückhalte
fliege ich so schnell
und wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel beim
fliegen steuerung drücke dann wird sie
meint ihr wie wird größer und ich fliege
so schnell das ganze geht halt auch vorm
fliegen das habe ich halt grad gemacht
wenn ich allerdings schon im fliegen
drin mit und einmal steuerung drücke
fliege ich halt viel viel schneller bis
jetzt beispielsweise mein leben dann
zeige ich euch das noch mal mit dem
doppel w ich bin jetzt hier gelandet und
wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
doppelbrücke und schnell sprinten und
danach fliege dann fliege ich genauso
schnell wenn ich jetzt immer steuerung
drücke dann geht's halt nicht noch
schneller
aber man kann auf jeden fall schon
schneller fliegen der 1.8 und leute das
ist wieder eine sache dafür werde ich
geköpft gerade von euch in den
kommentaren com alle an ich kannte ja
schon ich bin viel besser blabla leute
aber es wird mir trotzdem mache ich
zugesehen hat und damit das endlich mal
aufhört habe ich jetzt vorgestellt damit
die meisten leute zufrieden sind und
dass es hier und jetzt kommt nummer fünf
den absolut krassesten weg den ich je
irgendwie vorgestellt hat glaube ich
also das ist echt krank nummer 5 wurde
mir nämlich zugesendet von alexander
zwar gläubig und erst so krank also wenn
ihr diesen command selber entwickelt hat
das bin ich mir nicht so sicher aber das
ist so krank also ich hab mir ein
command blockform ich dann allerdings
wissen wie man sich ein command blog
gibt das macht man griff dann
konkret also auch im namen meiner kraft
doppelpunkt command unterstrich block
dann bekomme ich hier in command blog
den kann ich dann einfach hier mit 60
irgendwo hinsetzen aber ist jetzt auch
relativ egal weil ich halt hier schon
ein habe den kann man halt so bauern in
dem man einfach dranbleiben muss ich
glaub ich nicht erklären
dann klickt ihr einfach mit rechts drauf
wenn dann machen wieder einfach geben
wir das wieder ein
das ist ein command ich blende euch
jetzt mal ein bild davon wie lang dieser
command ist das ist so irre
jedenfalls wenn man diesen commander
eingibt kann man einfach mal auf dann
klicken jetzt aktiviere ich das ganze
mal jetzt seht ihr schon was hier
passiert etwas gebaut habe ich das ganze
schon getestet
wenn wir in diesem haus gebaut da werden
jetzt auch noch command blogs
draufgesetzt gleich jeden moment und ein
bisschen gras et cetera und gleich sehen
wir dass unten steht ein blog sound
blabla 15 sekunden
jetzt warten wir noch ein bisschen ab 5
sekunden und gleich ist das ganze fertig
und dann müssen wir nicht nur noch
abwarten und jetzt haben wir nämlich
geben snowball einst von crafter und
dieser schneeball bewirkt etwas was ihr
noch nie so in minecraft zuvor gesehen
habt das ist das krasseste was ich je in
diesem spiel erlebt habe was ein
schneeball erreichen kann
also freunde ich nehme mir jetzt diesen
schneeball
ich werfe ihnen jetzt einfach mal
hierhin und jetzt achtet was dieser
schneeball macht guckt euch das an
er hat ein haus klein ist einfach nur
ein bisschen blöd ingeborg wir können
jetzt einfach mal beispielsweise ich
weiß nicht also jetzt hier ist auch
relativ flache flächen das ist relativ
gut so hier kann ich das ganze mal
machen und zwar jetzt diesen schneeball
diesen unfassbar glänzenden schneeball
ich werde den hierhin und ihr seht der
schneeball kreiert ein komplettes dorf
der generiert ein komplettes tor
verdammte scheiße der macht ein ganzes
dorf dieser command macht einfach dass
der schnee bald aber er fliegt
ringsherum diese häuser wartet schon
getestet hat man freundlich gesehen im
berg hat wahrscheinlich geklappt hätte
irgendwie so blöd auf den berg rauf
geworfen haben und dann konnten die
ganzen sachen hatten ja keinen richtigen
untergrund zum stehen
allerdings finde ich schon dass diese
generierung schon viel besser als die
meisten npc dörfer weil
nächstes mal die wege dazu richtig
funktionieren ok funktioniert auch nicht
so gut
jedenfalls ist dieser command wirklich
dieser command für so ein npc dorf und
dieses nbc das sieht sogar teilweise
viel schöner aus als diese anderen pc
das hat endlich mal ein anderes design
und wir haben halt auch so versteckte
sachen wie beispielsweise wieder ein
chart mit table und ein crafting table
und ich weiß gar nicht was man hier noch
alles hat um das ganze herauszufinden
könnt ihr einfach mal wie mache ich ihm
dass ich kann diesen code auf jeden fall
nicht der beschreibung packen weil da
das ganze so ein bisschen
ich habe ich ein bild eingeblendet also
wenn ihr wollt könnt euch ja probieren
und ich denke man findet ihr auch
irgendwo im internet
weil ich denke nicht dass der alexander
den selbst gemacht hat aber das war auf
jeden fall sehr sagt kraft jetzt kommt
die sonne rom ihr seht dass wenn ich mal
hierhin gucke werde ich vor
und ich möchte sagen freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat dann würde ich mich
sehr sehr doll aber einmalig freuen weil
wir mit der bearbeitung und so hat alles
wieder länger gedauert
die serie macht es viel spaß zwingen
will werde ich sie auf jeden fall
weitermachen fix könnte mir per mail an
konto ftt mail.com senden
ich hoffe dass da cool effect ankommen
die ich cool vorstellen kann und die
noch nicht vorgestellt wurde und nicht
fassen das nicht funktioniert weil da
kommt in letzter zeit immer relativ viel
an
ich kann auch nicht dafür garantieren
dass ihr die ganze sache noch nicht
kennt also ich habe am anfang nach dem
intrusion eingeblendet so ein paar
kommentare die immer wieder ankommen wo
ich mir denke alter ja toll da und so
nach dem motto aber ich würde auf jeden
fall sein
ich freue mich über den daumen hoch ich
hoffe es hat euch gefallen und dann den
wir uns im nächsten video wieder